one team that was active at the deadline
the miami dolphins traded a guy
and acquired a guy in trade deandre
washington arrives from the chiefs a
very
late round swap of picks like not even
anything to really
speak of but it shows that what happens
that
eighth week of the season can dictate a
last minute trade miles gaskin
gets injured on sunday he's going to be
out multiple weeks with an mcl sprain so
the dolphins have a need
and the chiefs have a surplus because of
the arrival of le'veon bell so deandre
washington
gets shipped to miami where he will
after week nine because he won't be able
to play this week due to the covet 19
protocols and the waiting period because
that
travel from one team to the next pierces
through the nfl's unofficial bubble
you need to make sure he didn't catch it
on the way from kansas city to miami
he'll be able to play come week 10 and
he'll help
pick up the gap uh that is created by
miles gaskin not being able to play
right also the dolphins traded receiver
isaiah ford
to the patriots that one's odd to me
because the patriots are the ones who
should be
selling and the dolphins are the ones
who should be buying the dolphins or the
contenders
the patriots are the team that is left
to making excuses and we'll probably
talk about that later but they are
excuses and they're not good excuses as
ben volunteer boston globe pointed out
yesterday this idea that it's a salary
cap issue
any idea why the patriots would have
wanted isaiah ford and why they'd make
that move at the deadline
because they're not folding the tents
nobody gave them the memo that they said
this year's over they don't give a damn
they're going to continue and he's going
to continue to be the curmudgeon he is
and he's going to grind and grind
and grind so yes i know there's a lot of
talk about all that stuff either way but
i think this is again
new england has always got their eye on
these undervalued receivers that they
liked in the draft and
you know hey sometimes it's the reason
they miss on some of these guys in the
draft but i think it's just a guy where
they had their eye on him they thought
he could help their roster a little bit
at the wide receiver position
i mean because they're getting almost
zero production really the only guy
right now that can separate from anybody
is dimir bird uh and so i think they're
still looking at it like
they're not gonna count themselves out
that the
you know the afc east and the seven
playoff spots and all like that they're
they're going to fight this out and see
if they can't go on a run and i think
that's
incredibly why yeah and look that's
that's an
argument that we may have later in the
program
but i look at it this way is isaiah ford
really going to make a difference
when has a guy acquired at the deadline
ever been the difference maker for a
team herschel walker 31 years ago
was supposed to be the difference maker
for the vikings and it ended up being
the difference maker for the cowboys to
the tune of laying the foundation
for a team that won three super bowls in
four years when and and
shireen williams and i were trying to
remember last night
during pftpm and i didn't remember to
research it last night and brainstorm on
it i can't think of a time
when a deal that was done during the
season delivered
a dramatically better team on the other
side right well
there was the amari cooper trade pete
just said that in my ear that's not a
bad
idea right but yeah i know it wasn't a
huge difference i mean
emmanuel sanders last year was certainly
a big
you know acquisition for the 49ers it
wasn't like oh my gosh
now they're going to the super bowl you
just knew that
they did even though they did but they
needed that help
that's that's all i'm saying hey i'll
say this year just so far what we've
seen
you know baltimore and yannick and
gawkway has a chance to maybe be that
type of guy i think there's more out
there than we can
we think you know did it always relate
to them being the super bowl winner
no but i feel like there's some i'm
gonna think about that
and as this show goes on i'm gonna throw
them out there randomly because i think
there's more out there than we're
we're remembering right now or
forgetting just shout them out as they
come together i will
pause and go back and yeah i will you
know i i just
i i i understand that strategy and
that's why i think a lot of these deals
don't get done you're trying to strike
the balance between
going all in now versus building for the
future
and i think the job security or lack
thereof of the coach and the gm
is a factor in how aggressive a team
will be
if you're on the hot seat and you got to
give up a first round pick a second
round pick whatever to get that guy
that's going to help you save your job
who cares i won't be here to use the
pick anyway so i think that's why some
teams have and all teams need to have
those checks and balances where it's not
just
one guy making these decisions but it's
multiple people who have a voice in it
to protect against the temptation
to sell out the future a future that you
may not be part of
in order to secure your ability to be
part of that future by getting a team
that's going to help you maybe get right
post a guy that's going to help you
yeah i think that's what new england's
doing i think that's a little bit about
what bill
is trying to say with you know the
excuse-making and all that
is that he's trying to say that a little
bit yeah
not that they've been salary cap hell
but they haven't been in a great
position the last two years
and i think he's looking at it like wait
we had a great run
and i wasn't going to just use all our
resources and
put us in a really tough spot just this
year you know and ruin the next few
years to go along with that and i think
that's what they're trying to balance in
new england at least that's my take on
it we'll see where that goes but
i think it is more about like the future
and setting themselves
up that way instead of just looking for
oh one year
we proved it this year it wasn't brady
it was belichick we proved that you know
this is this is a long race and i think
that's he's making the long play that
way
yeah i don't necessarily disagree with
that
but at the same time number one
i don't agree that they have been a team
that has taken liberties with the salary
cap and now the reckoning is arriving
that's just not factually
accurate and the thing that really
bothers me about it and i hadn't thought
of it while we were talking about it
yesterday i want your input on this
it occurred to me after talking to some
people yesterday because this is
something that has stirred up a lot of
dust in nfl circles the idea that bill
belichick would behave like a normal
human being and feel compelled
to do anything other than flash his
rings and say
check out the scoreboard jimmy yeah
we're having a down year
oh well at least i won't have to repaint
the back end of my boat from eight rings
to nine rings this year i mean
the idea that he would be as petty as
the rest of us
and as as uh neurotic as the rest of us
and feel compelled to come up with an
excuse in and of itself is stunning
but what it does it crosses a bridge
that the patriots have never crossed
that's why i wrote something yesterday
and said at when i tweeted the the link
out the patriot way has lost its way
because
you never make excuses if you're the new
england patriots you got an injury
too bad next man up you got a salary cap
problem
we never talk about that go out and play
bad weather who cares yeah
right the idea that he's even
articulating something that could be
characterized by the reasonable person
as an excuse is stunning chris because
the guys in the locker room hear it and
they're going to think oh well
standard's not the same this year it
will be next year but this year it's not
the same
we can relax a little bit but i mean i i
don't think that
last part will happen i don't know
listen maybe maybe it does maybe they
lose another game and then that finally
you know just puts the nail in the
coffin and then you do have guys led up
there in new england whatever that is
but i do think there's still you know
that building just knowing those coaches
some of those veteran players that are
there i'd have a hard time believing
that happened
but i am with you i get it you know i i
am
shocked that he kind of went down that
road
usually it's just like you know i got to
do a better job coaching and we all got
to do a better job playing and my
coaches got to coach better and
uh you know that's that's really all
there is to it we just haven't done a
good enough job
you know that's usually what his answer
is with that type of thing
so yeah i do think it shows a little bit
of the human side of him to maybe where
he is feeling somewhat insecure about
the situation to a degree right now
i'm sure he didn't think they'd be
sitting there at two and five and all
those issues
so uh i'm sure he's a little bit pissed
off about it i'm sure he's a little bit
pissed too maybe that he didn't
act more aggressively in the off season
to get some players and do things like
that
he's probably kicking himself in the
butt that way as well
you know it's actually stunning about
all of this as we look at the monday
night football game for week nine
the game against the patriots may
actually be that the game that the jets
have the best chance of winning before
their bye week
the way the patriots have been going
lately and the jets are so desperate but
they've been through the meat grinder
and all of a sudden this last meat
grinder not as difficult as maybe
it would have been earlier in the year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports